richard is going to be our first for the
day out of Irvine California hey Richard
how are you hi I'm fine Dave how are you
good what's your net worth sir about 3.7
million got it cool and what is that it
broken down into invested in well I've
got about 1.9 million in a rollover IRA
401k I'm even using an HSA for
investments and and those are invested
mostly mutual funds in a few individual
stocks and then what's the rest of it in
I got about a 1.5 million in my house
and then about another 300,000 in non
retirement mutual funds and cash okay
cool how old are you I am 57 okay how
much of this 3.7 million did you inherit
did you have as well cause of inherited
well I didn't hear it about 600,000 from
my parents and why I was it was about 10
years ago you were a millionaire all
right 35 yes I was okay so you inherited
600 K so this wealth is not there
because of that and what was your in vet
what's been your range of income through
your working lifetime
well it's plenty I do you would ask that
question so I did a little research on
on the Social Security site and I
started in 1983 at about 30,000 and I
had a maximum of about four hundred and
fifteen thousand ten years ago come on
what do you do for a living I'm a plan
manager of a medical device company okay
all right and what's your degree in
mechanical engineering and then I also
have an MBA okay all right cool what was
your GPA you know about a 3.0 okay cool
and how much of this wealth the 3.7 is
there because you borrowed money to
create wealth well I I would say the
only wealth that I built by borrowing
money is through my houses I've
I started out buying my first house for
150 about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and that's appreciated to you
know almost a two million dollar house
and then now well very cool very cool
what has been your pattern on giving so
your working life well I give about 10%
of my my gross income um it's it's not
all to the church it's a much of it as
to the church and then to many other
things and and I went through some hard
times about five years ago and I had a
real cash flow problem and the one thing
that I didn't give up was giving in and
I'm really you know I I just you know
just you know never regretted that I
always glad I gave and even when when
times are bad and how many books do you
read here average I read I read probably
one book every month or two you're on
but I like reading how to books and I
read a lot on the Internet just you know
learn how to do different things cool so
do you think this can still be done I
mean you and I are the same age if
you're listening the 25 year old version
of us that's out there listening to you
and we have this conversation can they
still do it and if so what advice would
you give to the 25 year old version of
you today
well I've got two kids that are about
that age and one of them thinks that
things times are different now than they
were back when I was a kid and we've
been having some discussions back and
forth about that when I graduated Dave
you probably remember this the interest
rate was over or the inflation rate was
over 10% mm-hmm and when I graduated
from college the the economy was really
bad yeah and you know what I really
didn't care I wanted a job and I just
you know it didn't really
bothered me that the economy was bad I
knew it was bad by you I could find a
job and I was selling real estate and
interest rates were you know fifteen
percent yeah
in turmeric you know people couldn't
afford to buy a house right but um but
anyway I think you know things are the
economy is pretty strong nowadays and
and I really you know I think there's a
lot of things to be to be excited about
a lot of things being encouraged about
and what's the one main thing they need
to do to be a millionaire help the two
most important to most valuable classes
I had in my career one was typing
because it saved me a lot of time from
hunting and pecking and the other was a
class they taught me about the
compounding of money and you know that
that was I had that in college and and a
slow and steady formula you know that's
it Suzanne Cleveland Richard honored to
speak to you sir congratulations you're
an economic ear oh you did it start with
nothing 3.7 million net worth this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]